the moment you make money certain things
change meaning a three dollar increase
isn't felt you know a you know gas
prices goes up two dollars you won't
feel it you're like ah gasp that was
filling up my tank at 80 bucks and
that's 110 bucks okay who cares just 30
bucks you know hey you know this thing
that we were paying this much money for
shopping's gone up every month 200 it's
not a big deal it's two hundred dollars
two person making money is not a big
deal of course to person that's making
fifty five thousand dollars a year or is
making eighty two thousand dollars
trying to take care of their husband
wife and three kids yeah they're gonna
feel it
[Music]
[Applause]